Transcription: Viji Gowri
Relecteur: eric vautier
Bonsoir à tous.
Je suis sûre que parmi vous,
certains connaissent le point commun
entre ces deux personnages de fiction.
On a d’un côté Monk,
le détective qui résout des énigmes,
assisté de son Infirmière,
et de l’autre, on a Howard Hughes,
dont la vie a inspiré le film Aviator
avec Leonardo DiCaprio.
Eh bien effectivement,
ces deux personnages ont des TOC,
des troubles obsessionnels compulsifs.
Et si, dans la fiction,
le TOC peut être vu
comme quelque chose de gentillet,
parfois même un petit peu glamour,
eh bien, dans la vraie vie,
c’est une maladie
qui peut être très handicapante.
Imaginez avoir, toute la journée,
des pensées angoissantes
qui reviennent dans votre tête
et qui vous contraignent
à faire certains comportements,
certaines choses, de façon répétée,
alors même que vous trouvez ça
complètement absurde.
Eh bien, c’est ce qu’a Monk, qui,
parce qu’il a peur des germes
et des virus,
va exploser son budget lingettes,
va se laver frénétiquement les mains.
C’est ce qu’a Howard Hughes
qui se voit contraint de répéter
certains mots ou certains gestes,
sous peine de voir surgir
une très forte anxiété.
Comprendre ce qui se passe dans le cerveau
de ces personnes qui ont des TOC
est quelque chose qui m’intéresse beaucoup
en tant que psychologue
et docteur en neurosciences.
Et surtout d’essayer de voir
comment est-ce qu’on peut essayer
d’appliquer ses connaissances
sur le cerveau pour enrichir
des techniques de thérapie
qui fonctionnent déjà
chez les personnes qui ont des TOC
et d’autres maladies de l’anxiété.
Et parmi ces thérapies,
on a la thérapie comportementale
ou comment arriver à gérer
ses difficultés psychologiques
en changeant son comportement.
Et puis, on passe de cette théorie
à la pratique en 2020.
Souvenez vous de ce début d’année,
une sombre histoire de virus
qui viendrait de Chine,
qui s’est transformée en pandémie,
qui arrive en France
et qui apporte avec lui la peur
quotidienne d’être contaminé.
Moi aussi j'ai eu peur.
Et si, au début, j’arrivais à prendre
un petit peu de distance,
même à plaisanter par rapport à cette peur
en me disant : « Ouais, c’est sympa,
c’est un peu comme un ‘vis ma vie’
de tes patients qui ont des TOC. »
Mais au bout de quelques semaines,
je rigolais beaucoup moins.
J’ai commencé à avoir du mal à dormir,
à devenir plus irritable,
à éviter de toucher
des choses à l’extérieur,
à laver mes courses,
puis finalement à ne plus vouloir
du tout sortir de chez moi,
par peur même de croiser
quelqu’un de l’autre côté de la rue,
sur le trottoir d’en face.
Et là, je me suis dit : « Stop, pause.
Qu’est-ce qu’il se passe ?
Est-ce que tu ne pourrais pas essayer
de faire ce que tu fais avec tes patients,
comme si tu devenais ton propre psy ? »
Je sais très bien que quand on est
face à cette épreuve qu’est l’anxiété,
on a tendance à mettre des choses
en place un peu de façon instinctive
et que ça ne marche pas tout le temps.
Et que face à cet échec, on peut se dire
que c’est une difficulté de ma part,
une faiblesse psychologique,
peut-être un manque de volonté.
Eh bien non.
Ce que j’explique à mes patients,
c’est que c’est votre cerveau
qui dysfonctionne.
Alors attention,
il n’est pas cassé, ni fêlé,
il dysfonctionne.
Imaginez que votre cerveau, ce soit
comme un orchestre symphonique géant
avec des millions, des milliards
de musiciens.
Et quand tout le monde joue
de façon harmonieuse, c’est joli.
Votre cerveau fonctionne bien.
Et puis, à un moment donné,
on ne sait pas pourquoi ;
il y a un groupe de musiciens
qui se sont trompés de ligne
sur la partition
et ils ont décidé, je ne sais pas
pourquoi, de changer de tempo,
mais en tout cas, ce qui sort
n’est plus du tout harmonieux.
Votre cerveau dysfonctionne.
Alors, on sait que quand on est
face à ce dysfonctionnement du cerveau
et face à cette peur qu’on ressent,
la peur d’être contaminé,
on a un ensemble de structures
qui gèrent les émotions
et qu’on appelle le système limbique
qui va s’activer.
Oui mais voilà, il n’y a pas que
la peur d’être contaminé.
Il y a aussi des pensées
qui tournent dans ma tête,
avec des hypothèses négatives...
Et si le truc là que je venais de toucher,
quelqu’un d’autre l’avait touché avant
exactement au même endroit et que
cette personne était contaminée ?
Eh bien, toutes ses capacités
de penser, de raisonnement,
elles sont possibles grâce à l’activité
de notre cortex préfrontal.
C’est une structure dans notre cerveau
qui nous distingue le plus
du primate non humain,
c’est à dire des singes.
C’est vrai que j’ai cette anxiété,
toutes ces pensées négatives qui arrivent,
et comme c’est très désagréable,
moi, je veux m’en débarrasser
le plus rapidement possible.
Alors je peux éviter tout simplement
de m’y confronter.
Je ne vais pas sortir, je vais rester
chez moi ou je peux faire des choses,
comme par exemple laver mes courses
ou utiliser des lingettes comme Monk.
Oui mais voilà.
Quand je fais ces comportements,
j’ai une diminution rapide
de l’anxiété et cette diminution,
elle est interprétée par mon cerveau
comme une récompense.
Et on a au cœur de notre cerveau
un ensemble de structures
qu’on appelle les ganglions de la base,
qui sont impliquées dans ce mécanisme
de récompense et également,
dans la création d’habitudes :
l’automatisation des comportements,
à force de répétition.
Le souci,
c’est qu’il va venir se produire,
dans mon cerveau
comme dans ma vie d’ailleurs,
un véritable cercle vicieux.
Plus je suis angoissé,
plus j’essaye de me débarrasser rapidement
de cette anxiété.
Oui, mais voilà, en faisant ça,
j’empêche mon cerveau
de s’habituer à cette anxiété.
C’est comme si je le rendais
de plus en plus allergique
à la moindre petite anxiété.
Alors, comment on fait
pour casser ce cercle vicieux ?
Ce cercle vicieux, on le retrouve
dans d’autres maladies de l’anxiété,
comme par exemple, la peur excessive
d’avoir honte lorsqu’on parle en public.
Celle-là, ça va, je ne l’ai pas.
Ça peut être aussi des phobies :
la phobie des rats,
la phobie des araignées.
Pour casser ce cercle vicieux,
malheureusement, les psys,
on n’a pas de baguette magique.
Par contre, je peux vous donner
une des techniques
de notre chef d’orchestre
pour redonner une harmonie
à notre comportement et à notre cerveau.
Et cette technique, c’est le cœur
de la thérapie comportementale,
c’est l’exposition.
Vous allez devoir accepter
de vous mettre dans des situations
où vous savez que l’anxiété va arriver.
Vous vous dites peut-être :
« Cette fois, c’est sûr, la psy est fêlée,
elle va me demander
de lécher la barre du métro. »
Donc non, rassurez-vous,
on ne va pas vous mettre
dans une situation
où l’anxiété est importante,
où cette situation pourrait être
même dangereuse.
On va commencer
par une petite dose d’angoisse.
Moi qui ne voulais pas sortir du tout,
je vais me dire :
« Allez, courage, Anne-Hélène,
tu y vas, tu sors cinq minutes.
Juste cinq minutes.
Puis tu le fais plusieurs fois par jour,
plusieurs jours de suite. »
Et au bout d’un moment,
l’anxiété sera beaucoup diminuée,
même peut-être nulle.
Et là, je vais pouvoir passer
à un quart d’heure
et je vais encore le répéter
et ainsi de suite.
C’est un petit peu comme si
je désensibilisais mes neurones
à cette anxiété.
Alors peut-être vous dites-vous :
« Si elle savait tout ça, la psy,
pourquoi elle ne l’a pas fait plus tôt ? »
Effectivement, je me suis dit :
« Pourquoi tu n’as pas fait ça
plus tôt ? »
Tout simplement, parce que mon cerveau,
votre cerveau vous joue des tours.
Il vous biaise.
Il a tendance à vous pousser
avec plus de force,
plus de motivation vers quelque chose
qui va vous produire
une récompense immédiate,
maintenant, tout de suite,
même si on sait que ce n’est pas
la meilleure dans l’absolu.
Et ça, ça a été démontré
de façon expérimentale.
On est bien en psychologie cognitive,
où on a pu réaliser une expérience
et on a vu que vous préférez recevoir
100€ maintenant, tout de suite,
que 120 € dans un mois.
Alors qu’on est d’accord,
le cash flow n’est pas du tout avantageux.
Mais, ce qui m’a vraiment motivée à agir,
parce que ça m’a piquée dans mon orgueil,
c’est quand je me suis souvenue
qu’on ne voyait pas ça que chez l’homme,
mais aussi dans d’autres espèces
et notamment chez les pigeons.
Je me suis dit : « Ce n’est pas possible,
il faut que tu fasses quelque chose.
Tu sais que cette anxiété,
ton cerveau va te pousser
à t’en débarrasser immédiatement
et qu’en faisant ça,
au lieu de l’annuler, de la diminuer,
tu ne vas faire que la renforcer
à long terme
et que tu peux changer ça en affrontant
et en changeant ton comportement
de façon régulière et progressive. »
Ce dont je me suis souvenu également,
qui m’a encore plus motivée,
c’est qu’en changeant mon comportement,
je peux aussi arriver à changer
l'activité de mon cerveau.
Ça a été démontré de façon expérimentale.
J’ai un ensemble de patients
qui avaient des TOC, des vrais cette fois,
où on a vu que les dysfonctions cérébrales
qu’on pouvait observer dans leur cerveau,
elles diminuaient de façon significative
dès six semaines après le début
d’une thérapie qui comportait
ces séances d’exposition et que
c’était même visible de façon durable
puisque mesuré jusqu’à six mois
après la fin de la thérapie.
Alors, même si j’espère que
vous n’atteignez pas encore aujourd’hui,
le budget lingettes de Monk,
ni le handicap social
de notre Howard Hughes.
souvenez-vous,
quand vous êtes dans une situation
où vous vous sentez anxieux
et que vous jugez cette anxiété
comme étant excessive, trop,
que vous avez le pouvoir
de dompter cette anxiété
en changeant votre comportement,
en vous exposant
de façon régulière et progressive.
Vous avez, vous, le pouvoir de
reprogrammer votre cerveau.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)